TOWN HALL QUESTIONS TO THE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN.
THEY HAD ADVANTAGE OVER
BERNIE SANDERS IN THIS CASE.
JOINING US ON STAINING NRA
SPOKESPERSON DANA LOESCH WHO
WAS THERE LAST NIGHT.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
KATIE PAVLICH.
COMMUNITY CORRESPONDENT AT
HOME GERALDO RIVERA.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> AND DAN BONGINO.
>> WHAT'S UP, BRO.
[CHANTING U.S.A.]
>> Sean: THIS IS GREAT.
FIRST I WANT TO SAY I
OBVIOUSLY DIDN'T WATCH
BECAUSE THEY ARE ON AT THE
SAME TIME BUT I WATCHED
LATER.
AND NUMBER ONE, YOU DID A
PHENOMENAL JOB UNDER THE
MOST DIFFICULT CIRCUMSTANCES
CIRCUMSTANCES.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Sean: BRING US BEHIND THE
SCENES.
YOU WERE CALLED A MURDERER,
BURN HER, WHAT ELSE?
>> YEAH, WELL, LET ME SET
THE STAGE FOR YOU AND FIRST
OFF I WANT TO SAY THAT IT'S
HARD BEING A TEENAGER, IT'S
HARD BEING A GRIEVING
TEENAGER AND HARD BEING A
GRIEVING TEENAGER EXPLOITED
BY THE MEDIA BEING ASKED TO
GRIEVE PUBLICLY ON THE
NATIONAL STAGE.
THIS WAS AN ARENA FULL OF
SURVIVORS, VICTIMS' PARENTS
AND OTHER COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
THERE WERE OVER 7,000 PEOPLE
THAT WERE IN THIS ARENA,
SEAN.
>> Sean: UM-HUH.
>> AND WHEN WE ENTERED YOU
KIND OF ENTERED LIKE YOU
WERE FLOYD PLAY WEATHER
GOING INTO THE RING.
LITERALLY YOU CAME IN FROM
PART OF THE ARENA AND WALKED
THROUGH BETWEEN ALL THESE
PEOPLE.
AND YOU GOT UP ON STAGE.
IT WAS PRETTY CHAOTIC.
IT STARTED EVEN BEFORE I GOT
UP ON STAGE TO TALK.
AND I, THE WHOLE REASON WHY
I SHOWED UP THERE IS BECAUSE
THE MARCH IS MADE UP OF OVER
5 MILLION MEMBERS WHO ARE
ALSO PARENTS.
>> Sean: I'M ONE.
>> YOU ARE ONE AND YOU ARE A
PARENT.
WE DIDN'T DO ANYTHING WRONG.
>> RIGHT.
WHY IS IT THAT WE ARE HELD
RESPONSIBLE WHEN HERE AS YOU
MENTIONED JUST TODAY WE
LEARNED THAT THE SHERIFF'S
OFFICE, HERE HAD YOU A
DEPUTY WHO WAITED UPWARDS OF
4 MINUTES BEFORE THEY WENT.
IN SEAN IT WAS REPORTED THIS
MORNING THAT THE PARENTS HAD
REPORTED THIS MURDERER TO
POLICE BEFORE.
THERE IS A REPORT OUT THERE.
THE RECORDS HAVE BEEN
DISCUSSED IN MEDIA, WHERE
THEY SAID THEY TOLD POLICE
HE HAD THREATENED PEOPLE
WITH A GUN BEFORE.
HE HAS HELD A GUN TO OTHER'S
HEADS.
I'M NOT A MEMBER OF THE FBI.
I'M THOUGHT A MEMBER OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
I LOVE WHAT THEY DO AND
APPRECIATE WHAT THEY DO.
BRIAN: YOU ARE NOT DOING
THIS BECAUSE YOU ARE PAID.
>> I HAVE BEEN A SECOND
AMENDMENT SUPPORTER AND NRA
LIFETIME MEMBER FOR ALONG
TIME.
>> Sean: THAT WAS A CHEAP
SHOT.
>> THAT WAS A CHEAP SHOT BY
THE SHERIFF.
>> Sean: THAT'S FINE BUT
WHAT HE DID WAS WRONG.
>> THAT WAS WRONG AND HE HAS
QUESTIONS TO ANSWERED.
>> Sean: WE HAVE YOU FOR TWO
SEGMENTS WHICH IS GREAT.
WHAT OTHER NAMES WERE YOU
CALLED WHILE ON THAT STAGE.
>> I WAS CALLED A SEE YOU
NEXT TUESDAY.
THEY SAID BURN HER.
MURDER YOU
MURDEREROU
MURDERERS.
I HEARD A LOT OF MURDERERS.
CHANTED ME SHAME AS I WALKED
OUT.
DID I NOT.
I LOOK ATTAR SINGLE PERSON.
>> THEY.
ED JERRY SPRINGER?
>> HONESTLY.
CNN SHOULD HAVE LEFT.
>> THE OKAYAL JERRY SPRINGER
>> THE OKAYAL JERRY ORINGER
>> THE OKAYAL JERRY OKANGER
>> THE OKAYAL JERRY OKAY ER
>> THE OKAYAL JERRY OKAY -- ORI
>> THE OKAYAL JERRY OKAY -- ORA
>> THE OKAYAL JERRY OKAY -- ORL
JERRY SPRINGER.
>> THAT WAS THE MONEY SHOT
THEY WANTED, I'M SURE.
PEOPLE TRY TO RUSH THE
STAGE.
THERE WAS A WOMAN WHO RUSHED
THE STAGE.
>> Sean: THAT'S SCARY.
>> AT ONE POINT JAKE TAPPER
TURNED TO ME AND SAID DO YOU
HAVE AN ESCORT HAVE YOU GOT
TO GET OUT OF HERE RIGHT
NOW.
IF I DID NOT HAVE A THREE
PERSON DETAIL WITH ME, I
WOULD NOT HAVE GOTTEN OUT OF
THE ARENA.
>> Sean: THAT'S SCARY.
>> THAT'S NOT EXAGGERATION.
>> Sean: GERALDO, ONE OF MY
BEST FRIENDS IN LIFE.
WE DISAGREE ON SOME THINGS.
YOU BELIEVE NUT SECOND
AMENDMENT.
>> I DO.
>> YOU AGREE WITH WHAT I
OUTLINED FOR SECURITY
MEASURES.
>> I ABSOLUTELY AGREE WITH
IT DANA SAID IT'S HARVARD
BEING A TEENAGER.
I'M THE FATHER OF FIVE, DOOR
OF THEM HAVES PAD THROUGH
THE TEENAGE THIRLS IT'S HARD
WHY WOULD THEY RAISE THE AGE
WEAPONS 20 TO 21 AS THE
PRESIDENT ADVOCATES.
THIS SIMPLE CHANGE.
I WANT THE NRA TO EMBRACE
THE CHANGE.
[CROWD BOOING]
>> I WANT THE NRA -- HERE IS
A KID WHO WAS VISITED 39
TIMES BY THE COPS.
HERE IS A KID THEY WOULDN'T
LET HIM CARRY A KNAPSACK
INTO THE SCHOOL.
>> THEY BANNED THE BACKPACK
BUT DIDN'T BAN HIM.